dry ice
is one of the coldest substances on
earth
this is what it does to a flower
and check out what it does to this
action figure
ouch now what would happen
if you swallowed dry ice
what would it do to your skin
how much could you eat before it hurts
you
and how would it affect your stomach
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you ate a brick of dry ice
dry ice is a solid form of carbon
dioxide
and it's as cold as minus 78 degrees
and sometimes people eat this stuff
it's an ingredient that's occasionally
used in cocktails and
ice creams but it's only safe in
tiny doses so now instead of having it
mixed with other foods what would happen
if you ate an entire brick of dry ice
but first how would you get it
well you could just buy it but let's try
making some
on our own dry ice comes from carbon
dioxide
gas this gas can be as cold as -56
degrees
but for it to become dry ice
it needs to be even colder and to do
that
it needs to be pressurized and cooled
when it's released from the mold back to
normal atmospheric pressure
it forms liquid carbon dioxide
and now that we have our liquid it's
injected
into a block press which converts the
liquid into a solid
okay now we have our dry ice what
happens now
[Music]
well now that you have your brick of dry
ice
before you put it in your mouth you'd
first want to touch it
if you were to just poke the dry ice
with your finger
it would come back red with a slight
prickling sensation to it
that wasn't so bad okay so
why not try picking it up with your
hands well
because after just a few seconds of
having the dry ice in your hands
your skin cells would start to freeze
and then
die if you kept it in your hands any
longer
your skin would begin to turn blue and
gray
and eventually you'd lose all sensation
in your hands
and now after learning about how
damaging this can be to your body you're
still
curious enough to see what would happen
if you ate this brick of dry ice
are you serious okay fine
so as soon as you ingested the dry ice
you'd immediately feel the same
sensation you did
on your hand but in your mouth
your tongue and mouth tissue would begin
to sting and
feel incredibly numb and don't forget
about your teeth
you know how bad it feels when you chew
ice cream
yeah imagine that but much much worse
your entire mouth would be frozen in a
matter of seconds and
the longer you kept the dry ice in your
mouth well
it would only get worse eventually you'd
lose feeling in your mouth
forever but we're not even close to
being finished with the dry ice yet
you'd still need to swallow it as
the dry ice went down your esophagus
you'd feel a little tingling there
and then it would travel down to your
stomach
as it's in your stomach the dry ice
would heat up
and form gaseous carbon dioxide
this is because as dry ice heats up
it doesn't become a liquid but rather a
gas
hence the name dry ice and with this gas
in your stomach
you'd start to feel bloated and then a
sharp pain
and don't forget about the frost bite on
your stomach lining
luckily you could burp some of this gas
out of you
relieving some of the pressure you'd be
feeling but if you continued to eat dry
ice
the pressure from the gas would continue
to build
your stomach would expand and get harder
as the pressure continued your stomach
would rupture at this point you'd
experience
severe pain and vomiting if you didn't
get to the hospital
immediately you'd die oh
so please don't try this at home let's
just keep dry ice to
cool party tricks and something you'd
occasionally see in your ice cream
dry ice is definitely something you
don't want to eat but
what about something like gallium
well that sounds like a story for
another
what if